and I've asked Steven strogatz I've  asked Jim Simons I want to ask you is  mathematics invented or is it discovered  what I think is that actually it's one  of those cases where there is not an  objective answer it depends on how you  look at it so for instance and to give  you an analogy this happens in quantum  physics all the time for instance you  ask is an electron a particle or a wave  and the answer is it's neither and both  in some sense it depends on how you ask  it depends on from which angle you look  it is like Boris complementary principle  the two properties seem to be  complementary but I think it's both SML  in other words there's some elements in  other words which where they discover  but if you look at it in a certain way  if you look another way it represented  by humans but who are humans anyway who  are we